alrighty everyone it is time to talk
about episode 7 of The Lost of us TV
show only two episodes left that
stresses me out also before we go any
further I usually don't wear lipstick on
YouTube Take This Not lipstick it's like
colored lip balm but I busted my lips so
we're trying to hide that so episode
seven are really all about Ellie which
because I wasn't watching previews I
somehow totally missed was going to be a
thing but this is very much an episode
based on the Last of Us Left Behind DLC
and I very much appreciate the deeper
insight into how Ellie became who she is
as a character because I still maintain
that I feel like the show version of
Ellie and the game version of Ellie are
quite different having the flashback not
just to everything they have with Riley
but also to who Ellie was in school and
how she treated her peers how she was
treated by her peers explains a lot more
of her character um in a way that I felt
was totally justified it didn't feel
like filler to me at all I saw some
people say that and I totally disagree
um it answered a lot of questions that I
had about Ellie and also
damn Bella Ramsay's performance in this
episode was fantastic and even with all
of that said like feeling like it
justifies this version of Ali I feel
like it was a really faithful retelling
of uh Left Behind as well so obviously
this episode would be set just a few
weeks
um maybe a couple of months before Joel
and Ellie actually met so it's not like
we're seeing her childhood but we were
seeing a little bit of what her life
looked like before she won on this
adventure with Joel who goes on a brief
adventure with uh who we presume is her
best friend slash crush Riley and going
to the mall in this show
um Not only was the set design once
again absolutely incredible but I also
felt like
a sense of wonder personally like it
wasn't just that it looked very very
very good I imagine this is a real Mall
in Canada that they had to like add set
dressing to um with just a fantastic job
totally believable I couldn't tell if it
was a set or if it was CG or if it was a
real mole it looked amazing but there is
something really fun about seeing a mall
in this universe for the viewer as well
really interesting episode in terms of
like seeing brands that we recognize
things that exist in shopping centers
like uh the body shop or a Victoria's
Secret or a GameStop but obviously that
dilapidated and run down
um I think the GameStop sign had the tea
flickering or something
there's something about that that just
like warmed my heart I don't know why I
worked there uh for years technically EB
Games which is the Australian version
but yeah seeing the mole and having
Ellie be as excited as she was to see
all of it um was nice because it was
mirrored by me being because I'd see all
of it and to see different parts of it I
I really just enjoyed that environment
probably more than any we've seen so far
in the show and it's been full of
beautiful environments and of course we
got a lot of Easter eggs things that are
basically exact from the uh Left Behind
DLC like the Carousel and the photo
booth and with all of those positive
things in mind I feel like the point
where this episode showed up was was
very good
um we came off of some dark heavy very
emotional grueling scenes and to see two
kids play in a mall effectively
um even though it still ends in a dark
negative way that was like exactly the
right time for this kind of episode
they're giving us a lot of levity and a
lot of variation between episodes and I
really appreciate that and it was really
nice to see Ellie have fun to see her
act like a kid to see how she reacted to
the escalators
which is something that like I totally
did when I was a kid I [__] loved
escalatus you're always trying to run
backwards up the escalator if you're a
kid like that stuff was just really fun
related to that also I felt like the
music in this episode was particularly
fantastic we had some some great classic
songs woven into the story here in a way
that I just generally really appreciate
um Good Chemistry Between the two
characters and some good action at the
end there as well when of course the
Love Story falls apart thanks to a third
Uninvited Guest
which related can we just address how
long they were there for making noise
before that thing actually showed up or
in previous episodes they're on them
like immediately I get that the show is
all about entertainment and that not
everything needs to be taken that
seriously but I have questions but then
yeah ending of course with the loss of
Riley and at least fear of that
happening again and giving her
motivation to really save Joel
um that's really come to light in these
last two episodes very strongly I think
it was a thing that I didn't like so
anticipate
come if you watch my earlier episodes I
was like I just I don't buy that they
like each other she's very harsh but I
think it's paid off in the way that I
kept saying I'm sure they'll pay it off
it just hasn't paid off yet and I do
feel like uh episode six and seven
really sealed the relationship but it
still feels like we have a lot of ground
to cover in two episodes
like I don't feel like Joel is yet at
the point that he would be doing the
thing he's going to do
um do two episodes ain't that much it's
it's seems like it's gone so fast and I
don't want it to be over yet
so all of that said
um I previously have said that I felt
most episodes were rushed they were too
fast I wanted extra details or slightly
less detail on certain aspects
um this is the first episode that felt
like it was maybe a little bit longer
than I needed it to be I did think that
it was very very well written this
episode I buy the relationship between
these two teenage girls living in the
world that they're living in I think the
four Wonders of the World thing
um
it was maybe a little bit longer than it
needed to be and that there was a lot of
really good stuff here and it's not like
I would have cut a lot from it but there
were some moments that I don't think
needed to be just just
um as built out as they were in favor of
probably I would have added a little bit
extra on to the end of this episode with
Ellie doing everything she could to save
Joel Beyond just the stitches of course
I also think that this episode
um because it is so similar to episode 3
with Bill and Frank
is not quite as strong regarding the
love story and the loss and and because
of that it's it's hard not to make the
parallels to episode 3 which I think did
it so well like so flawlessly that
episode 7 is not anywhere near as
heartbreaking or at least I definitely
didn't have the same reaction to it yeah
I ultimately definitely felt like it was
really good to see it it was a really
good choice to put it where they put it
um it was really nice to see how Ellie
became who she became and see a
different side of her and essentially
get some insight into the side of her
that she's sort of locked off to be
honest fantastic performance from Bella
felt like she did a really really really
great job I think I just still at this
point would have liked to see a bit more
Joel and Ellie in this episode and I
think that that's really just because I
feel like there's so much ground to
cover in the next two episodes and I
don't feel like they're at the point yet
where Joel would make the choice he has
to make but uh it's so hard to say this
without seeing the whole show you know
they could blow me out of the water and
make a ton of progress that next week I
don't know do I and I think maybe I feel
this way just because we're coming off
of the Kathleen stuff which I ended up
feeling similarly about which is like I
don't need Kathleen fleshed out that
much it's not to say I wanted to be one
note or anything but um I would have
liked to see more Joel and Ellie and I
think that that is consistently the way
that I'm feeling at this point because I
figure the games are about them the show
should be about them but I'm still very
happily along for the right I also think
that like the way that I'm feeling is
probably just because I know what's
going to happen right like if I didn't
know what was going to happen and what's
inevitable
um
I probably wouldn't feel this way at all
it's so hard to watch something that's
such an accurate
um faithful Recreation
for the most part like the core themes
are the same of course there are
differences between the show and the
game which I'm also very happy about but
it's difficult to watch something and
not feel very attached to it and like
what's happening and what's going to
happen and where they should be at a
certain point when you kind of almost
feel like you know these characters
which is really strange and I think that
is it
I'll have a chat up tomorrow with Lucy
James from gameswatch Giant Bomb and
Khalifa Adams from spawn on me about
episode six and seven because I wasn't
able to do discussion last week because
I was away at a video game conference
and hope to continue streaming the game
tonight tomorrow night I don't know soon
there's a lot going on right now
um and as we get closer to the boxing
match I'm probably gonna have to like
pull back content even more so just
trying to manage where I can let me know
what you guys thought of episode seven I
would love to hear your input I'm sure
that uh people are gonna tell me I'm
overly critical again even though I
still think the show is very good and
very much like it to be clear hi I'm
Alana I will see you guys next time bye